[Musica]
e come gruman cantandolo online facendo
in aree di sé lunga riga di dio venir
traendo guai ombre portate dalla detta
brega perché io dissi maestro chi sono
quelle genti che laura nera si castina
la prima di cui nouvelle tu vuoi saperne
disse quelli allotta fu imperatrice e di
molte fa venne a vizio di lussuria fussi
rotta che libito fé licito in sua legge
per torre biasmo anche era condotta e la
è semi ramis di cui si legge che
succedette a nino e fu sua sposa tenne
la terra che il soldan corregge l'altra
è colei che sanchez e amorosa e ruppe
fede al cep nardi si che ho poi e
cleopatràs lussuriosa elena vedi per cui
tanto reo tempo si volse e vedi il
grande achille che con amore al fine
combattevo de di paris tristano e più di
mille ombre mostro mie nomi nomi adito
che mordi nostra vita di partire o
jacques io ebbi il mio dottore udito
nomar le donne antiche i cavalieri pietà
mi giunse cui quasi smarrito poi
cominciai poeta
volentieri parlerei a quei due che
insieme vanno epyon sì al vento esser
leggeri e degli emmy vedrai quando
saranno più presso a noi allor tu li
prega per quella morte e mena e dei
verrà se tosto come il vento a noi ci
piega mossi le voci o anime affannate
venite a noi parlarsi altri non nega
quali colombe dal disio chiamate con ali
alzata e ferme al dolce nido venne un
parlare dal voler portate cotali uscire
dalla schiera o 20 ton
venendo a noi per la re maligno si forte
fu l'affettuoso grido o animal grazioso
e benigno che visitando viper la air
perso noi che tenemmo il mondo di
sanguineo se fosse amico e re
dell'universo noi pregheremo lui della
tua pace pockaj pietà del nostro mal
perverso di quel che udire che parlarvi
piace noi udiremo e parleremo a voi
mentre il vento come fa chi tace siede
la terra dov'è nata fui sulla marina
dove il po discende per aver pace con i
seguaci suo amore call call gentil ratto
s'apprende prese costui della bella
persona che mi fu tolta il modo ancor
m'offende amor ch'a nullo amato amar
perdona mi prese del costui piacer sì
forte che come vedi ancor non
m'abbandona
amor condusse noi ad una morte caina
attende che avete ac spesso queste
parole dall'arci for porte quando io
intesi quell'anima offense china il viso
è tanto il tenni basso finché il poeta
mi disse che pensi quando io risposi
cominciai all asso quanti dolci pensieri
quanto disio meno costoro al doloroso
passo poi mi rivolsi a loro e parla io
francesca i tuoi martiri all'agri marmi
fanno cristo è dio ma dimmi al tempo dei
dolci sospiri a chi e come concedette
amore che conoscesse i dubbiosi di siri
e della me nel suo maggior dolore che
ricordarsi nel tempo felice nella
miseria e ciò sa il tuo dottore ma se a
conoscerla prima radice del nostro morto
aiko tanto affetto
dirò come colui che piange e dice noi
leggevamo un giorno per diletto di
lancia all 8 come mor lo strinse soli
eravamo e senza alcun sospetto per più
fiato e gli occhi gesù spinse quella
lettura e scolo rocci il viso ma solo un
punto fu quel che ci vinse quando
leggiamo
desiato riso esser baciato da cotanto
amante questi che mai da me non vi ha
diviso la bocca mi baciò tutto tremante
galeotto fu il libro e chi lo scrisse
quel giorno più non vi leggemmo avante
mentre che l'uno spirto questo disse
l'altro piange sic e di pietà de io
venni man così come morisse e caddi come
corpo morto cade